PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In last lecture we talked
about finding the derivatives
of trigonometric functions.
In particular, the sine function
and the cosine function.
So today let's do an example
of putting that into practice.
So here's a function:
h of x equal to sine
of x plus square root
of 3 times cosine of x.
And I'm asking you to
find which values of x
have the property that
the derivative of h of x
is equal to 0.
So why don't you take
a minute to think
about that, work it out on
your own, pause the video,
and we'll come back and
we'll work it out together.
All right.
So you've hopefully had a chance
to look over this problem,
try it out for yourself.
Now let's see how
to go about it.
So we have the
function h of x-- it's
equal to sine x plus
square root of 3 cosine x--
and we want to know when its
derivative is equal to 0.
So in order to
answer that question
we should figure out what
its derivative actually
is and try and write down a
formula for its derivative.
So in this case
that's not that bad.
If we take a
derivative of h, well h
is a sum of two
functions-- sine x
and square root of 3 cosine x.
And we know that the
derivative of a sum
is just the sum of
the derivatives.
So we have the h prime
of x is equal to d
over dx of sine x plus d
over dx of square root of 3
times cosine x.
Now we learned last
time in lecture
that the derivative of
sine x is cosine of x,
and we learned the derivative
of cosine of x is minus sine x.
So here we have a
constant multiple,
but by the constant multiple
rule that just gets pulled out.
So this is equal to cosine
x minus square root of 3
times sine x.
So this is h prime of x and now
we want to solve the equation h
prime of x equals 0.
So we want to find
those values of x
such that cosine x minus square
root of 3 sine x is equal to 0.
Now there are a couple
different ways to go about this.
I think my preferred way is I
would add the square root of 3
sine x to one side, and then
I want to get my x's together,
so I would divide by cosine x.
So that gives me--
so on the left side
I'll be left with cosine
x divided by cosine x,
so that's just 1.
And on the right side I'll
have square root of 3 times
sine x over cosine x.
So that's just square
root of 3 times tan x.
Or, and I can rewrite
this as tan of x
is equal to 1 divided
by square root of 3.
Now to find x here, either you
can remember your special trig
angles and know which
values of x make this work.
Or you could apply the
arc tangent function here.
So in either case,
the simplest solution
here is x equals pi over 6.
So if you like, you can draw
a little right triangle.
You know, if this is x, if tan
x is 1 over square root of 3,
we should have this side
being 1 and this side
being square root of 3.
And in-- OK, in that case,
in this right triangle
the hypotenuse would be 2.
And so then you, you
know, would recognize
this is a 30 degree angle,
or pi over 6 radian angle.
But one thing to
remember is that tangent
of x is a periodic
function with period pi,
so not only is pi
over 6 a solution,
but pi over 6 plus
pi is a solution.
So that's 7*pi over 6,
or pi over 6 plus 2*pi,
which is 13*pi over 6,
or pi over 6 minus pi,
which is minus 5*pi
over 6, et cetera.
So there are actually
infinitely many solutions.
They're given by pi over 6 plus
an arbitrary multiple of pi.
So then we're done.
So I do want to mention,
though, that there's
another approach to
this question, which
is, we can start by multiplying
this expression for h of x.
So if you look at
h of x-- that's
sine of x plus square
root of 3 times cosine x--
it resembles closely one of
your trigonometric identities
that you know about.
So in particular, to make
it resemble it even more
I can multiply and divide by 2.
So I can rewrite h
of x equals 2 times
1/2 sine x plus square root
of 3 over 2 times cosine x.
And now 1/2 is equal
to cosine of pi over 3.
And square root of 3 over 2
is equal to sine of pi over 3.
So I can rewrite
this as 2 times--
what did I say-- I said
cosine pi over 3 sine x
plus sine pi over 3 cosine x.
And this is exactly what you get
when you do the angle addition
formula for sine.
This is the expanded
out form, and so we
can apply it in reverse
and get that this
is equal to 2 times sine
of x plus pi over 3.
So, so far we haven't
done any calculus.
We've just done-- so in this
solution, our first solution
we did some calculus
first and then
some algebra and trigonometry.
So, so far we've just done
Now the points where h
prime of x is equal to 0
are the points where the
graph of this function
has a horizontal tangent line.
So either you can compute its
derivative using your rules
or by the definition.
Or you can just say, oh, we
know what this graph looks like.
So I've sort of drawn
a schematic up here.
So this is a graph, this graph
is OK, so this is the graph,
y equals 2 sine of
x plus pi over 3.
It's what you get if you take
the graph y equals sine x,
and you shift it
left by pi over 3
and you scale it up
by a factor of 2.
So this here is at x
equals minus pi over 3.
This root is x
equals 2*pi over 3.
And the points
we're interested in
are the points where there's a
horizontal tangent line, where
the derivative is 0.
And so there's one of these
right at this value, which
is pi over 6.
And then the second one is
this, is that minimum there.
So that happens at x
equals 7*pi over 6.
pi over 6 because
for the usual sine
function it happens
at pi over 2,
but we shifted everything
left by pi over 3.
And so pi over 2 minus
pi over 3 is pi over 6.
And here for this, for
just y equals sine x,
this minimum would
happen at 3*pi over 2,
but we've shifted it
left by pi over 3.
And so on. you
know, every, there's
another trough over here,
and another peak over there,
and so on.
So that's the second way you
can do this question using
this cute trig identity here.
And that's that.